[Music]
a rude hollywood screenwriter a man
undone by his high school sweetheart a
small role on the big bang theory lance
barber has played a ton of roles beyond
young sheldon keep watching to learn
more one of the most prominent running
gags in the big bang theory involved
sheldon telling stories about his
childhood in texas sheldon's stories
portrayed a group of dysfunctional
countrified southerners they couldn't be
more different than the timid and
analytical sheldon however fans have now
gotten a first-hand perspective of
sheldon's family with the spin-off
series young sheldon sheldon sometimes
described his father as a crazed drunk
who used his wife's favorite cookware
for shooting practice however young
sheldon portrays him as a simple
blue-collar football coach who does his
best for his family even if he makes
mistakes the two versions of george
cooper senior don't always line up but
neither one is strictly bad actor lance
barber makes the most out of playing
george on young sheldon however george
cooper is far from barber's only role
throughout his career he has played a
number of other characters that may make
george cooper senior from young sheldon
look familiar lance barber has no
delusions about his level of fame barber
has been a career actor for over 20
years but has rarely held the spotlight
instead barbara has made his living
playing a series of smaller roles his
earliest role was as a man in a coma on
er later roles included parts in yes
dear what i like about you and come to
papa in 2014 barber told the battle
creek inquirer i was a character guy i
was heavy i was likable i guess so i had
the opportunity to play best friend guy
to the lead guy despite his lack of
mainstream notoriety he still loves
being an actor
i feel very lucky as an actor we all
want more work and more quality work but
i have zero complaints being sheldon's
dad isn't barbara's only recognizable
performance years before the big bang
theory debuted barber landed a recurring
spot in one of hbo's most underrated
series the comeback the show was about
an aging sitcom actress named valerie
cherish valerie allows a film crew to
document her return to show business
like the office and arrested development
the comeback reveled in creating awkward
moments between its characters on the
show lance barber played the role of
paulie g the showrunner of valerie's
latest sitcom gig room and board the two
maintain an ongoing feud throughout the
comeback and remain enemies even after
the fictional sitcom is cancelled
unfortunately unlike the office it never
reached a high degree of mainstream
popularity the show was cancelled after
just one season that is until the
comeback made a comeback over the years
the series had garnered a cult following
on the internet in 2014 the show was
revived for a second season
reintroducing the main characters nine
years later in an interview with bustle
barbara called the show's return a dream
come true this time paulie g is
different when we meet him in 2014 he's
gotten clean following his addiction to
heroin during the events of season one
he seems much more willing to work with
valerie instead of against her though it
isn't long before new tensions arise in
their relationship aside from the
comeback the latter half of the 2000s
saw primarily bit roles for lance barber
he had one episode appearances in a
variety of shows including joey the
mentalist monk and csi miami in the
2010s he showed up in even more series
like grey's anatomy kian peel how i met
your mother bob's burgers brooklyn
nine-nine blackish and faking it his
most recognizable role during this time
however was as bill ponderosa and it's
always sunny in philadelphia like most
characters in the series bill ponderosa
is a certifiable scumbag
miss me don't answer that all right
although dee once had a crush on him in
high school he's a hedonistic narcissist
in the present day he cheats on his wife
abuses his kids and is addicted to
practically everything under the sun he
also briefly becomes dennis's
brother-in-law after dennis marries and
then divorces his sister maureen bill
was last seen in season 13 where he's
invited by frank to attend the super
bowl so why would barbara look so
familiar to big bang theory fans long
before young sheldon was announced lance
barber actually had a one-time
appearance on the big bang theory as a
different character whenever you see
george cooper senior being a
well-meaning dad on young sheldon you're
also looking at leonard's high school
bully jimmy speckerman speckerman shows
up in 2011's the speckermen recurrence
which focuses on speckerman's failed
attempts to make amends with leonard
holy crap man it's good to see you
you too
however speckerman doesn't actually have
good intentions he only apologizes to
leonard while drunk and then denies his
actions the next day sheldon helps his
friend leonard stand up to the bully he
never seems to notice that speckerman
looks just like his father check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]